[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here's Morgan uncensored
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
well they wouldn't know the truth they
just smack them around their privilege
chops Harry and Megan detonate what's
left of their raw Relationships by
releasing two nauseating Netflix
trailers tonight revealed that even
those are packed full of lies so will
they now finally be strict of their
remaining titles
remember Donald Trump hosts a secret
dinner with Kanye West who then goes on
to be banned from Twitter after posting
a swastika in the Star of David and
defending Hitler I'll talk to the rabbi
who was at Donald Trump's inaugurations
he still stand by the former president
and should he run again
plus England's team into the
quarterfinals of a World Cup as far as
becoming one of the most entertaining of
all time as football declared victory
over the virtue signals
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening for London welcome to
Pierce Morgan uncensored Harry and Megan
the dreariest couple in the history of
planet Earth
famously abandoned their Royal duties
for a life of privacy they left the
Goldfish bowl of Great Britain for the
camouflage of California remember
famously sheltered from the evil British
press and since then they've kept an
incredibly low profile as they vowed to
if you excuse the massive book deals the
Silicon Valley startups the preaching
videos about well-being the podcast the
speeches and the major network
intervenes with everyone from Oprah
Winfrey to James Corden but it barely
had been seen or heard at all have they
well on Thursday they'll quietly and
apologetically release their 100 million
dollar documentary series on Netflix
there are trailers for this and viewers
with sensitive stomachs should look away
now
[Music]
why did you want to make this
documentary
no one sees what's happening behind the
closed doors
[Music]
utterly nauseating uh I mean literally I
literally recoiled while watching it
of sanctimony the fake drama the hammy
woe is me that's been going on now for
years the somber tickle of the piano
geezy staged black and white photographs
of this very ordinary young oppressed
couple
having what appears to be some tiny
semblance of fun in their California
Mansion as they count all their money
incredibly it gets worse
I had to do everything I could to
protect my family
I mean nothing says protecting your
family like doing a reality TV flying
the ball documentary about every aspect
of your family life for the delectation
of the entire planet does it Harry well
the brain pack of Paparazzi
photographers jostling the space to
Hound the happy couple that's what we
just saw right childhood photographs
clearly intended to evoke the tragic
death of his mother Diana
both photographers we just saw weren't
actually interested in Prince Harry at
all they were at the premiere of a Harry
Potter movie five years before Harry
even met Megan there weren't any Royals
there at all
there's apparently sticky paparazzo
lurking above the sussexes was actually
invited there to cover their meeting
with Archbishop tutu in Cape Town
another photo used in the promotions
shows Harry's outstretched hand
apparently shielding the couple from
photographers only it's actually a
cropped photo of Harry with
ex-girlfriend Chelsea Davey taken in
2007 and a press scrum shown dashing
after the unhappy couple was actually
chasing after reality TV star one of
their compatriots now Katie Price at
Crawley magistrates Court
ironically for a couple of repeatedly
sued newspapers for intrusion and
inaccuracy
they've just put a lot of Whoppers into
their trailers as before we even get to
the main event
when the stakes were this high
doesn't it make more sense to hear our
story from us
oh shut up
what do you mean the stakes of this High
who Do You Think You Are
other latte munching
imbecile living in luxury in California
while the rest of the world is a
constantly living crisis moaning and
whining about institution which gave you
the titles on which you now trade
millions of dollars
when you're talking about Stakes are
there other than the massive gigantic
stake you're currently plunging into our
monarchy over here
and as for telling their story sorry if
I missed something I thought you've been
telling your truth which is often a pack
of lies from the moment you abandon this
country
well today's new trailer doubles down on
the last trailer and there's more tears
remember that clip of Megan wants
showing us how she could cry like that
at the drop of a little tiny tarnished
Tiara remember that she could do it like
that
just bear that in mind when you watch it
did you get that one
shameful comparisons for Princess Diana
I remember Prince Harry being very very
angry about the media exploiting his
mother for commercial game yeah what has
he done with this Netflix series he's
used his mother to sell it
could there be a more grotesque
exploitation or a more hypocritical one
than him using his Dead Mother's imagery
to engender sympathy for himself again
as the great victim in this world
I find it all puke making
and I speak to someone who's actually in
one of these things I pop up
yeah me
um and to my astonishment I was being
very nice about Meghan Markle
let's have a listen
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Applause]
[Music]
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about heat
trip it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want the
history to repeat itself
[Music]
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
God you wouldn't know the truth if it
hit you around the back of your head
and Harry here's the point
we're not really interested in your
truth you've been saying it for the last
two three years your version of what you
think happened
and yeah I did say Megan was becoming a
royal rock star and I'm pleased you
quote me in there because it shows I was
like the rest of the British media very
positive about your new bride until your
Mutual Behavior became hypocritical and
ridiculous after the wedding
you'll claim that you're the victims of
a dirty game is especially Brazen given
that these trailers have been released
to deliberately overshadow a visit by
The Prince and Princess of Wales United
States
the timing of course is Unforgettable
unforgivable if entirely unsurprising a
typically cynical ploy to overshadow a
vitally important Royal tour the first
sense of death of Queen Elizabeth what
about his father in all this a man has
not even been coronated as king yet
still mourning the death of his mother
is he going to cop it in this series you
can bet your life you will Charles is
going to have to take it again from his
son with no ability to speak out and
return fire
this series will do great numbers for
Netflix
but maybe not for the reasons they hoped
the Oxford English Dictionary defines
hate watching as the activity of
watching for the sake of enjoyment
derived from mocking or criticizing
that's a measure of success Harry and
Megan you're going to have a Smash Hit
but of course the real match of success
of both of them will be the same as it
always has been how much damage can they
inflict on our royal family on our
monarchy how can they make it all about
them how can they continue to play the
victims when they live in such
unparalleled luxury the other side of
the world
this gruesome twosome only survived by
cashing in on what's left of their Royal
status now
I said it before I'll say it again
tonight King Charles has stripped them
all their remaining titles and cast them
out from any connection to the royal
family any of them trust them as far as
I could throw them because without it
they're just whining Millennial windbags
with a permanent victim complex knowing
that victim mode is what makes them all
the money
well joining me now is Royal author Tom
Barr former Butler to Princess Diana
Paul Burrell I'm a Lauren commentator
Paula Roan Adrian who's turned out
looking magnificent tonight is this
prompting me to stumble into a where are
you really from question and ask me
where my people are from here is
absolutely I wish he wasn't on air after
all that um and I know you took partner
debate about it I mean my thing is quite
interesting a lot of friends of mine
and some family actually well I think
the treatment of Lady season has been
way over the top she's an 83 year old
woman didn't really know what she was
doing dug herself into a hole probably
didn't even realize until the balloon
went up the next day where's our sense
of forgiveness all this kind of thing I
personally felt that her asking where
this lady came from given she was
dressed in her Guard from her African
and Caribbean heritage
I thought it was perfectly reasonable to
ask where are you from
right to the point where she tells you
I'm born in Britain and I'm British at
that point the interrogation has to stop
and she carried on in what became an
increasingly cringe-making way which I
think if I had been a black woman in
that position I would have found
actually very offensive and I'm glad
that you said the word interrogation
because that's what it was it's the way
it felt right however we we stopped
there with our agreements because you
you reference her as being this 83 year
old woman who was digging herself a hole
we're talking about somebody whose job
it was and and who was present
throughout 50 years in terms of
diplomacy assisting the queen as her
lady in waiting this wasn't a woman who
lived at the bottom of my street in
Plaistow or Upton Park in eastender okay
this was a woman who was well educated
and should have known better and with
age comes wisdom there's no excuse you
must know I know her very well what was
your reaction to it all I actually felt
so for the whole situation developing
the way it did because Lady Susan is 83
and she's not up on the woke society and
and what we should say or shouldn't say
oh how many policies are in place how
many how many how many training sessions
do they have no they don't yeah
they answer they signed letters how
could they be so apparently insensitive
after all the aggravation around Meghan
Markle because because the Palaces it's
dysfunctional you know that peers it
doesn't work the way we think it works
it works 100 years ago why should age be
an excuse I know lots of people in their
80s who don't feel it necessary to be
that clumsy when they speak to black
people why should we give her a pass
well you know peers on this subject I
really want to pass because I don't
really think you know what don't pass
because
we need to do
we have uncomfortable discussions
they're not allowed to pass Tom I've
never known you parsley
I don't think this is Susan because you
think it's not really your place
and felt racially offended I think um
I'm sure she did feel offended I'm sure
she did that that's I have no doubt
about that at all is whether the
situation should have risen out I really
don't I wasn't there and I'm going to
pass okay uh let's move on to what we're
going to talk about this isn't this this
Netflix series I mean it seems to be to
me to be confirming everyone's worst
fears probably worse actually and her
then whacking the media is one thing
they've been doing that the whole time
whilst using the media when it sees them
as they are now on Netflix
if you're King Charles if you're the new
Prince of Wales this is an absolute
Hammer blow this series this is the real
life Crown sticking it to them right
when they least want anyone to stick it
to them they're trying to rebuild the
monarchy after the death of our greatest
Monarch that's my objection with it well
I think it's worse than that because I
think it's the lies which is the bigger
objection and first of all the whole
premise of today's trailer was about the
impossible for a woman outside of
becoming inside look Kate Middleton did
it perfectly acceptable Wessex did it
yeah and Diana was not an outsider and
the Spencer family whereas inside as you
can be the second thing which I find
really objectionable is their attack on
the media this is a couple as you write
this in your introduction with Oprah
Winfrey the cut variety never stop it
doesn't stop and so they are the
greatest manipulators and you've
forgotten in your list Erma scobius
frightening Freedom right where they
lied on those that they have had no
collaborating collaborating so they are
really very they're the rotten but I
think the most important element now is
how is the palace going to react and I
would you do if you were there I think
the only way they can react is after the
Netflix series giving an interview I
think either the king or William have
got to break this uh idea of never
complaining never explain they've got to
take a head off you know what if you lie
down with dogs time you get flu well I
don't I disagree with you because I
think that it'll be a global sensation
then comes the book and I don't think
that the royal family can allow the lies
which the Sussex is a perpetuation to go
on I mean it's the sheer number of lies
in the trailers about these pictures
none of which actually depict what we're
being led to believe they're going to be
much worse we know that we've known that
for months yeah we've been saying it for
months this is going to be a bombshell
it's Armageddon yeah it is we talked
about this a lot how do you defend what
they're doing given that clearly the
intent now is very clear to do as much
damage as they can to the Royal Family
monarchy regurgitating stuff they've
been saying now for years to maximum
damaging effect
how do you defend it
is this isn't about bending this is a
's identifying pain and what we are
witnessing here are two people who are
in pain I don't believe it but you don't
have to no but you are witnessing the
format you don't claim the role of the
life in this series you don't have to
accept you don't have to accept that
you've insulted me you don't have to
accept it but you will have to accept
the Fallout from insulting me because I
am going to react to it and this is the
problem that royal family has I don't
think the answer is for them to do an
interview I think that would be the
worst thing that they could do what you
should do is get in a professional
mediator what they need to do is now
start dealing with the problem the
problem exists and we had a glimpse of
that with Miss Hussey
don't conflate the two well you say that
but when we're talking about race
racism learning about it long before
lady I have I have that was their truth
is their lies that is the whole point
they invention we know in Oprah the
release 17 lives right I'm going to
become accounting on Netflix there were
six lies in the trailers about the
pictures which don't depicts which were
no doubt produced by the trainee
part-time person who was putting
together come on that was nothing to do
with Harry and me here's my question for
people you're King Charles what on Earth
do you do given that one of these two
people trying to ruin everything you
represent is your own son you take away
the titles I agree with you you do
absolutely they don't want to be members
of the royal family so why should they
trade on that big of the prince this
this because you will always be a prince
he will always be a president she's the
princess well so that's the problem is
that the lies have got to be confronted
you cannot rely on you know a reporter
shouting at William as they did after
the Opera everything are you racist
problem with professional help but it
don't fall into the Trap of fighting uh
hate bombs with hate bombs because
that's what's happening
Harry are hurting they
[Music]
yeah to me and I always you've been
quite supportive of Harry absolutely you
know I I just crossed a line for you
I've crossed the line because
um
Harry decided to take this path to
America he decided to do what he did for
the right reasons to protect his family
I thought great Diana would have
applauded that his mother would have
said great Harry you're doing the right
things she would not have applauded what
he's doing now no the commercialism
around it she never took a scent never
took a penny monarchy she was a great
supporter of Monica she said to me I
long to hug my mother-in-law I longed to
put my arms around her I know what goes
on inside her head and she was very
proud of her boys being members of the
royal family she always thought it was
Harry's job to be William's wingman to
be there for him on his path to monarchy
that was his job Paul if one of your
family was doing this constantly for
huge amounts of money just just abusing
you and your rest of your family would
you be as tolerant of it you have to be
because the problem's never going to be
resolved I'm not sure you do actually I
think you're actually reaching a drift
yeah
I'm Brothers of this to me what did I do
actually after years of you you go I'm
done yes I'm done you do yeah
you say no we're talking about racism to
trash their families we're talking about
trash in the family you're talking about
people who feel that their mental health
so all right
as you know I don't believe a lot of
that stuff I know right tell me one bad
thing
that Charles or William has said
publicly about Megan and Harry I
it's all one way
well I just think you're going to start
at the beginning
um that um Megan came to Britain
thinking she was going to be Numero Uno
she was gonna be the star she wants
couldn't understand she didn't
understand the hierarchy system she
didn't want to understand when she
understood it she wants it out they all
went out of their way to help us
60 people were helping her she had
really intelligent devoted women highly
or who understand what it used to be a
black female who understand what it is
to be an American to understand what it
is in terms we've only seen the trailers
and the series drops first three
episodes on Thursday yeah I can't bear
we'll all watch it whether we want to or
not
they are in danger of destroying what is
good about Britain royal family our King
not yet had his coronation and William
and Kate who are going to be our future
okay they can't do this in public I'm
going to leave you two to walk over to
the sunset together holding hands The
Odd Couple Tom good to see you thank you
all very much coming next they come at
their mouths in protest but Germany was
left with their feet in their mouths and
crashing out of the World Cup early I
want to talk to legendaries and I'm
talking a proper Legend sports
broadcaster Bob Costas most famous
commentator in American Sport and one of
my sporting Heroes call them next about
this whole issue of sports washing
virtue signaling is is it something
athletes should be doing should they
leave it alone what does the World Cup
tell us about this and what does he
think of it join bobcat off the bike
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
guess she's got a brand new show on talk
TV at nine o'clock Friday nights live
honestly I don't care I'm a bit rude why
just a bit of fun Friday night's live
I'll I will be honest with you I'm not
too honest the criticize was so bad come
on Cristiano give it a chance we're
going in why is it not gonna work tell
me you have to be charismatic yeah well
people have to to feel some connection
with you to be good looking helps too
all right cheeky oh bloody hell Friday
at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on Politics
on the economy and across the World At
Large music makes sense opinions that
matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well silicone came near Westbound from
tiller again we're posting a vile tweet
of a swastika immersion of the Star of
David which came of course after he met
with Donald Trump at Mar-A-Lago along
with another anti-semite should Trump
denounce him is it all too late we'll
talk to the rabbi who addressed Trump's
inauguration shortly
the first World Cup in Qatar is becoming
the most entertaining perhaps of all
time a bit of disappointment for those
who attempted to overshadow the
tournament but sanctimonious virtue
signaling including memorabiliter
Germany players who covered their mouths
before their game against Japan before
losing the game 2-1 and crashing out of
the tournament they were mildly widely
mocked by Japanese supporters and katari
TV hosts who cover their mouths of wave
goodbyes the Germans got the first
flight home well Arsenal Legend arson
bengan our FIFA set of development
summed it up rather well
and the teams as well
who were mentally ready like you even
said that the mindset to focus on
competition and not on political
demonstrations
well I'm thrilled to be joined now by
the sports casting Legend Bob Costas one
of America's Traders sporting
commentator is a veteran of a record 12
Olympic Games winning no fewer than 28
Emmy Awards for his Peerless commentary
Bob uh what a treat to have you on Piers
Morgan and says so thank you so much
hi Spears great to see you again even
from a distance I have one Daytime Emmy
and I've never covered an Olympic so
you're slightly ahead of me and I bow I
bow to your superiority quite willingly
and this whole issue Bob I just couldn't
think of a better person to talk to
about where the line is drawn between
political activism or social justice
activism for that matter and sports and
this issue of Sport washing whether it's
engulfed with the live golfers and the
PGA at War whether it's what we've been
seeing in in Qatar at the world cup with
people saying they're going to protest
they're not protesting them being
ridiculed for it others like the Iranian
players making a genuinely powerful
stand against oppression of their women
back home going right back perhaps to
Colin Kaepernick who was of course the
NFL player who took the knee for the
first time and the England players at
this world cup are still taking the knee
uh in in his his honor I guess because
he was the one who started it so it's a
lot of stuff going on on in this area
what is your overview of political
activism and Sport
I think Pierce we have to make
distinctions from one situation to
another one person to another just
because I may agree with a general cause
or issue and with the person's right to
make a statement doesn't mean that I
have to agree with everything they say
under that manner Colin Kaepernick is a
good example there's no question even if
some people may overstate the severity
there's no question that police reform
is an important issue in the United
States and where it needs to be reformed
the burden primarily falls upon people
of color in the United States that's
legitimate but then when Colin
Kaepernick subsequently says I don't
vote because the oppressors will never
allow you to vote your way out of your
oppression when he said that Barack
Obama was President I guess he didn't
vote When Donald Trump ran against
Hillary Clinton and then Donald Trump
became president that's a silly and
naive thing to say even if I respect the
initial point that Colin Kaepernick
wanted to make within this this year's
World Cup the Iranians not only are
making a very important point it's a
courageous point to make because heaven
knows what might happen to any of them
when they return home and they're
directly involved in that some might say
that others at a safe distance covering
their mouths or whatever are merely
virtue signals but then it all circles
back to the ioc in their case putting
two Olympics in China another one in
Vladimir Putin's Russia and FIFA now
going to Qatar as you have stated
previously and I agree with this
obviously every nation has flaws and
problems and issues and things that they
need to correct and shame in their past
and maybe in some cases in an ongoing
way but then there are nations in the
here and now we're not talking about
history in the here and now that are
fundamental human rights abusers Qatar
is one of those China is certainly one
of those Putin's Russia is one of those
and these athletes will never have a
platform that that will draw as many
eyes and make as large an impact as they
do at an Olympics or at a World Cup and
it's ironic that FIFA and the ioc say
let's keep politics out of this please
keep politics out of this but they're
the ones who put politics in it by
placing these events in places like
Qatar and Sochi and in Beijing so as
long as the the protest whatever it may
be is not within the match for the game
itself because people do want to watch
the game or the match for its own sake
and it's very exciting I think you
undermine your own cause if you get in
the way of the game itself but
surrounding the game or for commentators
in the programming that precedes the
game or at halftime or post game then I
think it's okay you see well a a
brilliant response as I would have
expected I'm very thoughtful a nuanced
in many places I would take issue I
think about a couple of things you said
the main one I think is this there's a
lot of I think over-the-top virtue
signaling about Qatar from the UK in
particular not from America
interestingly but in the UK a lot of
sort of anger built up in the very last
minute about a World Cup that was
awarded 12 years ago the Middle East has
never had a World Cup if the stick to
beat the Middle East on human rights is
ill treatment and migrant workers and
LGBT rights for example then you're
basically saying you can't have a sports
tournament in the Middle East at all
because they would all have similar
issues with migrant worker treatment and
outlawing LGBT rights completely in most
countries but you'd also have the same
situation in Africa you'd have the same
situation in China the same situation in
vast ways of India or Russia and so on
and so I I think what I would say back
to you Bob on that point once you start
putting the moral Halo on about human
rights
I'm not sure you can end up with many
places in the world which are clean
enough to actually host say a World Cup
and I'll throw it back to you in this
way you and I have both actually got
into trouble at different times in our
careers in America you're more
successful than mine about gun control
for example you you expressed a view
about gun control uh when you were on
air once and got a lot of blow back I
did a lot more and got a lot more blow
back and got told to go back to the UK
but the next World Cup is in America
shared with Canada and Mexico should
people be taking a strident view for
example about gun violence in America as
an issue about abortion laws which just
dramatically change which are very
contentious in many other parts of the
world what America's done there in other
words it's if you continue down the road
of putting a Halo on and deciding who is
fit to host these things I think you've
got to be consistent and accept that
every country including America
including Britain which helped America
legally invade Iraq of course in 2003
that we all have actually pretty big
abuses which would be quite hard to
defend
yeah there are matters of degree the
points you make are legitimate and by
the way just parenthetically as you know
my point about guns in America and as it
affects athletes was to say that there
is a gun culture in America not to take
issue with the fundamental idea of the
Second Amendment which is a big deal in
the United States but even if you
believe in the Second Amendment you
should also be able to recognize that
there's a lot of irresponsibility
surrounding guns and some of it had
crossed over into sports so that was the
comment I was trying to make but
sometimes people get irrational about
certain things hear what they want to
hear and take it from there so forgive
me for that parenthetical aside I think
the point you're making is legitimate
but it's a question of degree if we're
looking for a perfect Nation maybe you'd
have to hold every Olympics in
Switzerland which ironically enough is
where the ioc is located in lausanne but
we're talking about degree the United
States most certainly has its problems
and athletes historically and sometimes
movingly have read registered their
complaints and their protests about that
but Qatar
Putin's Russia Beijing they are
fundamental human rights abusers it's
definitive about them rather than flaws
that the Nations we're talking about the
United Kingdom or the UK uh America
Canada they are actively trying to
address however imperfectly however
haltingly it's within their their DNA
it's within the American Constitution to
address
these uh inequities and injustices
whereas it is the policy of the
governments of Qatar and China and
Putin's Russia to oppress people and
engage in in many cases Russia in this
case uh International treachery did the
United States make a huge mistake Post 9
11 in invading Iraq yes they did but I
think you could make a strong case that
that is not fundamentally what the
United States is about
I mean it's an interesting rejoinder I
mean obviously having been in Qatar last
week there's a lot of I think resentment
and raised eyebrows about what they
perceive to be the West's moral
hypocrisy and they feel quite strongly
about it that they've been over
demonized and the West under demonizes
itself and doesn't want to turn the same
critical eye to its own moral failings
and they point it like in the UK for
example we have appalling drug abuse now
in our country it's sort of Rife with
drugs now appalling knife crime
um you know all sorts of metrics for
sort of moral uh degeneration if you
like which is anathema to a lot of
people in the Middle East where they
don't there's drug drug laws are
incredibly Draconian you know there's
very little knife crime at the crime we
have in the UK and so on so it was
actually being there on the ground was
really quite interesting it's not to
defend everything that they stand for
but I do think it's a commonality
through the Middle East uh pretty much
what Qatar represents and they believe
they're representing the whole region
with the World Cup and I have to say
having been there Bob it was a very good
atmosphere it felt very safe everything
was you know running very smoothly and
it's not like uh I know the Germans ran
the trains well under hit late well I
was there they all seem to be having a
pretty good time I have to say
well the World Cup is a wonderful event
and from what I hear from a distance uh
it has been run smoothly just as you say
uh
oh one thing I heard repeatedly when I
hosted the Olympics I always asked the
heads of the ioc when they brought them
in for an interview what is it with this
seeming affinity for authoritarian
Nations uh with the ioc and the answer
always was we feel that by holding an
Olympics anywhere it helps to spread the
Olympic ideals of equality and diversity
and democracy it helps to spread those
ideas
how's that working out
with uh with China how's that working
out with Putin's Russia and we'll see if
there are any reforms in Qatar or Iran I
tend to doubt it right Bob I can talk to
you all night uh what I wanted to ask
you before I let you go you've
interviewed so many Fascinating People
in the sporting world if you could
literally
if it was your last hour on Earth which
I hope won't come for a very long time
who would you of every sports sports men
and woman you've ever met who would you
most like to spend that hour with
Dead or Alive well if it's the one
all right well then you just answered
the question Dead or Alive because of my
Affinity for baseball I would like to
sit Babe Ruth down with Jackie Robinson
Babe Ruth was the greatest player
pre-integration Jackie Robinson is not
the greatest player although he's a
great player but he's perhaps the most
significant player uh in the modern
history of baseball and to have them
talk not only about baseball but about
the country they grew up in uh Ruth at
the uh the turn of the century and
Jackie Robinson in the middle of the
20th century that's the interview I'd
like to conduct
brilliant I would I would choose sir
Donald Bradman who statistically an
Australian batsman cricket uh
statistically the greatest Sportsman of
all time the gap between him and the
second place international average
player was greater than the gap between
one and two of any other sport in the
world
you know I once referred to Sir Donald
in a piece on HBO as the Babe Ruth yes
of cricket and in fact there's a great
picture of the two of them meeting It's
a Wonderful Village yeah Bradman and
Babe Ruth it's an amazing picture uh Bob
thank you so much for joining me I
honestly I could talk to you all night
you're such a fascinating guy and I
really appreciate it
thank you pierce hope we talk again soon
good to talk to you all the best Bob
Costas well coming up next suspended
from Twitter again this time Kanye West
posts a vile tweet of a swastika merge
with the Star of David he'd just come of
course from a meeting with Donald Trump
at Mar-A-Lago with another anti-semite
but Trump hasn't announced him yet
should he or is it too late will Rabbi
Marvin heyer who addressed Trump's
inauguration think so he joins me live
next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
at nine o'clock Friday nights live
honestly I don't care I'm a bit rude why
just a bit of fun Friday night's live oh
I will be honest with you I'm not too
honest the criticize was so bad come on
Cristiano give it a chance well go on
then why is it not gonna work tell me
you have to be charismatic yeah well
people have to to feel some connection
with you to be good looking helps too
all right cheeky football bloody hell
Friday at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dunn join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large
it makes sense opinions that matter
so don't miss first edition with me Tom
Newton Dunn each week night at 10 P.M
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
Kanye West or yay as he refers to be
known as Simon genius but also
profoundly troubled is used about Jewish
people completely unacceptable only
driven six weeks ago and challenged to
remember what I felt was his
anti-semitic ranting at the time our
explosive exchange got many views and
headlines around the world
let me ask you yeah if I can about the
allegations that you have made
anti-semitic comment when you said on
Instagram I'm a bit sleepy tonight but
when I wake up I'm going Defcon 3 on
Jewish people what did you mean by going
Defcon 3 on Jewish people being that I'm
an Entertainer I've been wrong so many
times by Jewish businessmen I didn't say
Defcon on anybody though you said Defcon
3 on Jewish people that is racism yay
are you sorry you said that absolutely
not you knew it was racist but you
decided to do that because people have
been racist to you is that is that your
position I'm sorry for the people that I
heard I feel like I caught I caused hurt
and confusion
[Music]
thank you
well last week it emerged that yay sat
down at a private dinner at miralago
with former president Donald Trump and a
well-known Holocaust denying anti-semite
Nick Fuentes
and the big question is what should be
done about that should Trump be held
accountable give it he's not denounced
either of his dinner parties well I'm
not joined by The Man known as Hollywood
Rabbi Marvin High the founder of Los
Angeles Simon reasonfall Center and his
Museum of Tolerance he also spoke at
Donald Trump's inauguration the first
Orthodox Jewish religious leader to
address a ceremony and joins me now uh
Robert hi thank you very much indeed for
joining me I appreciate it what was your
reaction pleasure what was your reaction
when you heard about this dinner not
just with Donald Trump seeing Kanye West
after all he's been saying and in fact
since that didn't have far worse things
again but also this character Nick
florentes who by any yardstick is a
repulsive anti-semite
absolutely outrageous and Unbecoming of
President Trump children are Jews and
here as you know in The Hollywood
Reporter here's the photograph of him
hugging
uh West when in 19 this was in in 2018.
so in 2018 he shows everybody that he
loves the guy and then this anti-semite
it makes these horrible comments Jews
were born into money we need a
government of Christians Jews can be
here but they can't make our laws that
would be news in other words he's saying
that the Jews can live in the United
States they can't have any positions
because he's a notorious anti-semite
yeah and president Trump needs to do
what President Biden did which is to
condemn it if if he fails to condemn it
he's as guilty as they are well that's
what I think I think is I think in a way
it was terrible to have this dinner with
these two people
um but it was also reprehensible even
after the fiori that blew up he still
doesn't condemned them and we've now
seen this unedifying spectacle of Kanye
West going on a conspiracy shock joke
Alec Jones's show and saying he admires
Hitler and then he posts to Twitter a
swast in a star of David I mean I to me
Kanye West is done that should be the
last we see of him in a public domain
for that alone
absolutely and president Trump he is
definitely he's announced he's running
for president I'll tell you one thing
any Jew that votes for him under these
circumstances it would be astonishing to
me yeah and his family must be
embarrassed
you know his family is hasn't said
anything there's nothing to say his is a
president that basically he's running
he's running for announces himself that
he's running for president and then has
the excuse why did you invite these
people right now to meet with you oh he
says I didn't know it's on my agenda
that's nonsense
but you mean an assistant for the
president doesn't know that these two
anti-semites are arriving arriving in
the way to meet with President Trump
it's completely nonsense I mean the
reason I know it's not because I was at
miralago interviewing president Trump
back in April and his teaming with
Secret Service you don't think they go
over every single person with a fine
tooth comb all they're going to do is
Google Nick Fuentes and up Comes This
Litany of anti-Semitic outrages that
have spewed from his mouth
absolutely and the only way out of this
is for him if he wants to look I would
say this any Jew
that votes for president Trump if he
doesn't apologize and recognize that
what he did is outrageous I would I'm I
would be shocked yeah I completely agree
and what should happen with Kanye West
now he calls himself yay now but in the
immediate aftermath of some of his
anti-semitic ranting he saw horrible
anti-semitic placards go up over bridges
in Los Angeles where you are as a rabbi
in Hollywood how did that make you feel
terrible and Simon wiesenthal once I
asked Simon wisdom why do you live in
Vienna Simon the war's over you got all
these Nazis why are you living in Vienna
he says I'm living in Vienna because
they are still Nazis there and here's
what my point if Simon wisenthal we're
alive today he'd be living in the United
States because that's where the bigots
and the haters are what a terrible what
a terrible Twist and Turn of History yes
absolutely awful Rabbi hi thank you so
much for joining me I really appreciate
I completely agree with everything you
said I think it's reprehensible that
Trump had this dinner I think it's even
worse that he hasn't denounced the
people that he had it with particularly
given what is now been said by Kanye
West and particularly given his own
daughter is now Jewish and is married to
a Jewish man to me it's all it's all
completely unacceptable and I really
appreciate you saying even time to come
on the show thank you
thank you
we're coming next to our Shameless
former Health secretary isn't satisfied
just going to the Jungle he's now called
a book out blaming everybody but himself
and in particular claiming care workers
for spreading covid and Care Homes well
reaction from my pancakes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Friday nights live honestly I don't care
I'm a bit rude why just a bit of fun
Friday night's live oh I will be honest
with you I'm not too honest the
criticize was so bad come on Cristiano
give it a chance we're going then why is
it not gonna work tell me you have to be
charismatic yeah well people have to to
feel some connection with you to be good
looking helps too all right cheeky
football bloody hell Friday at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tom Newton Dan join me on first
edition a brand new current affairs
program which brings you tomorrow's news
today first edition is about making
sense of what's really going on in
politics on the economy and across the
World At Large music makes sense
opinions that matter so don't miss first
edition with me Tom Newton Dunn each
week night at 10 P.M
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back let's talk now to my
stunning fact this evening with one
exception obviously um with Emily
Sheffield Association
welcome to all of you well let's start
with the beast in the middle
um Matt Hancock have we managed to go
through a show without mentioning him
yet but this volume of Diaries is
brought out which looks suspiciously not
like actual Diaries the stuff he's
written after the event
the thing that's really incends to me is
that apart from the value takes no
accountability of anything himself is
the way he blames care workers for
spreading covert in Care Homes yeah not
himself so taking old people out of
hospital without testimony put him into
care care workers risking their lives
yeah that's my Hancock all over and I
think that book is he says it's his
Diaries I think it should go straight in
the fiction section of any
shop because he's not taking any
responsibility we can see how he's going
to play now at the at the inquiry and
why he went on I'm a celeb and sat there
with a toad on his head he used to turn
himself into some personality because he
can't he can't face the truth of what
happened we are afraid and we know
covered was it was a huge crisis and
would have hit any government but he
made big fatal errors and he won't own
up to them is it also something slightly
distasteful he keeps talking about this
great Affair of his hearts and
everything and parading the new
girlfriend around that he was fired over
you know because they were groping in in
Bridge locked animals and he's got his
family like watching all this good I'm
like it just all seems very distasteful
to me yeah it's also quite farcical that
this man somehow managed to run the
Health Service managed to have a family
life have an affair and also write in a
diary every evening like you're telling
me he went home right dear diary I just
don't believe it and the fact that that
poor woman is basically being you know
trounced out for the public to assess I
think it's really quite disgusting well
I mean we're just ways of doing this and
it seems to me I'm not making a moral
judgment about him he's perfectly
entitled to follow his heart wherever he
wants to do it but it is bizarre to see
a politician so Brazen like here's the
new love of my life and forget everybody
else and by the way I'm not to blame for
anything that happened in the pandemic
everybody else is especially you care
workers there's something so Shameless
about it all yeah but I think he's gone
with the plan whether we agree with it
or not that if that the only way to sort
of save himself was it did have to be a
real Affair of the heart otherwise the
whole thing just looks horrendous
because he's broken the rules to have a
bit of a fling with you know someone
he's working with while his wife who
allegedly had long covered was at home
looking after the three children
so I think that's his defense isn't it
that this was a true love affair to be
fair they've gone through the most
gruesome 18 months and they are still
together so I would say that was a true
I think there was true love you can wish
that happiness another reason I mean I
bumped into him Heathrow when he came
back eventually bumped into it was one
of the most awkward 100 meter dashes in
my life but I thought you were joking no
I don't know like that I literally that
that happened it was just me and him his
assistant and my driver for 100 yards
right are you imagine because I've been
kicking him all over the place and uh I
made small talk with it I said look I'm
on one level I admire your balls in
doing it right because to put yourself
into that but then there's something so
Shameless about him are we totally
Shameless that I'm not entirely sure I
do admire his balls because this is what
he does he's so Shameless at every level
there is a bit of the Harry and Megan
about him yeah creating his own truth
now he can you can give verifiable facts
to him that show it's not true what he
says it just ain't the case and it'll
deny it it will Brazen it out
what are your thoughts about this
Netflix series that I'm not going to
agree with what Kevin just said because
I think that Matt Hancock I think this
is an allegory for what entirely
happened throughout covert I think that
he lied to his wife and I think he lied
during covert I'm I'm really looking
forward to the Netflix documentary I
think this is the moment for Megan to
really you know speak freely that should
be speaking freely
for the last two years am I wrong I I I
I have to say it is the royal family and
if they've got something to say about
what happened then let them say it and
let the Royals say that's not true but I
think they should have their say and I
think everyone's coming down on them
incredibly hard I'm sorry we've just
someone who's just watched the fifth
series of the crown are we forgetting
the Prince Charles interview are we
forgetting the Tampax conversation are
we forgetting that these two these
children
family
yeah they never stop talking yes but I'm
sorry
good night
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guess who's got a brand new show on talk
TV at nine o'clock Friday nights live
honestly I don't care I'm a bit rude why
just a bit of fun Friday night's live oh
I will be honest with you maybe not too
honest the criticize was so bad come on
Cristiano give it a chance we're going
then why is it not gonna work tell me
you have to be charismatic yeah well
people have to to feel some connection
with you to be good looking helps too
all right cheeky
football bloody hell Friday at 9pm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]